you've given comments by KIA stammer and
Burton how do you and how does this
government Define a woman
um
to be honest Sean that's that questions
come slightly out of left field for me
um the
well biology sex gender
um
people Define themselves people Define
their own genders
he said that he believes 99.9 of women
do not have penises and I know it's a
strange thing for him to say but given
recent events in New Zealand
I'd ask again how do you define what a
woman is well as I I think as I've just
indicated I wasn't expecting that
question so it's not something that I've
um you know formulated pre-formulated an
answer on but in terms of gender
identity I think people Define their
gender identity for themselves
identification yes what about and if you
like an official or a wider societal
sense again I think we have rules in
place now if someone wants to change the
agenda on their birth certificate for
example there's a process that they go
through in order to do that
um I haven't got all of the I haven't
got the process chapter and verse in
front of me but it's available anybody
can look it up and see what that process
is one follow-up you described that you
thought some of posing Parker's views
were abhorrent could you tell us which
ones
um
I I think some of the the views being
conveyed around trans the transgender
Community some of the sentiments yes
some of the sentiment that she's
expressed towards the transgender
Community is abhorrent in my view well
that they shouldn't exist